let's discuss the health benefits
of
pizza now
is it possible to
have some health benefits from pizza yes
but you have to do the healthy version
of a pizza okay a keto pizza which i'm
going to give you the recipe now my
favorite food of all time is pizza i've
eaten a lot of pizza and i remember
growing up feeling so bloated when i
would eat the entire pizza i'd feel
sluggish and tired but i didn't care
because the taste was so delicious so
fast forward when i started keto in low
carb
i wasn't willing to give up pizza so i
searched out a really good recipe and i
did a video on pizza and i will put that
down below but i'm going to give you a
summary of that video today but what
would be the health benefits
of pizza well
if you do the version i'm going to
recommend you're going to go low carb
okay and when you go low carb you're
going to actually lower your insulin
when you lower your insulin you're going
to lose weight you're going to lose fat
on your liver you'll have cognitive
benefits your mood will be better you'll
have less blood sugar issues and less
cravings
and overall you're going to feel really
good so it is possible
to have your cake and eat it too when
we're talking about pizza there's a lot
of other foods that you can also eat if
you modify the recipes now a healthy
pizza is all about the ingredients and
the
most unhealthy part of a pizza is in the
crust because they normally use
wheat flour okay so this recipe is going
to be using cauliflower cauliflower can
mimic a starch okay
it's used in a lot of keto foods and
it's a very neutral food it goes with a
lot of other foods you can do
cauliflower rice cauliflower pizza crust
you can do cauliflower mashed potatoes
there's a lot of different recipes and
if you add
the right combinations of things it's
pretty darn close to the unhealthy
version
cauliflower is part of the cruciferous
family it has a lot of phytonutrients
and it has good amount of vitamin c
folate b12 b6 and cauliflower is pretty
low in carbs and definitely low in sugar
and high in fiber so i'm going to make
this very very simple and i'm also going
to tell you
a very big mistake to avoid when you
make this cauliflower pizza okay
the key is making the crust correctly
okay so
you're going to get a bowl and you're
going to combine two cups of cauliflower
shredded all right of course i'm going
to recommend organic cauliflower then
add two eggs the whole eggs of course
i'm going to recommend pasture raised
organic eggs okay not pasteurized eggs
pasture raised eggs and then two cups of
mozzarella cheese okay you can grate
that
and of course
definitely organic and as you're making
the material for the crust preheat the
oven to 425 degrees
then what you're going to do is you're
going to mix it all up really nicely and
get some parchment paper and form this
pizza crust okay and i usually put the
parchment paper on a cutting board okay
then what i'm going to do is i'm going
to take the entire cutting board with
the parchment paper and the pizza crust
that's going to go in the oven okay
after it's been
preheated and then i'm going to very
carefully
transport
the parchment paper part not the cutting
board but the paper with the pizza crust
into the oven okay so in other words do
not put the topping of the pizza
on the crust
as the first
heating
phase okay
you want to cook the crust
first
then pull it out then put the topping on
then put it back in the oven and we've
made this mistake in the past where we
puddle this material on the crust and
then stick in the oven
and it never comes out that good it's
all soggy and you cannot cook the crust
in the top material at the same rate
because they
the top's going to burn
and the bottom crust just needs more
time to cook now there's a couple
options with spices you can
bake the spices into the crust which is
might be a good idea or you can add that
on later but if you do you can add a
half a teaspoon of garlic half a
teaspoon of oregano and half a teaspoon
of
basil and then you can
put some sea salt on it some pepper
some other spices that you like so
sometimes i will bake this into the
crust sometimes i won't and as this
pizza crust is cooking um a minimum time
of cooking is going to be about 10
minutes but i would check it at 10
minutes because it might need 12
up to 15 minutes in the oven okay you
want to cook it until it's just slightly
browned then you're going to take it out
of the oven okay put it back on that
cooking board and then wait till it
cools off a little bit and then you can
start adding your toppings so i put a
low sugar type tomato sauce okay i'll
put that first
then i will put a layer of grated
mozzarella cheese then i will put either
sausage or pepperoni sometimes i like to
cut a tomato in little chunks and put
that on the pizza maybe with some
olives and maybe even mushrooms so
whatever topping you like go ahead and
put that on the top of that crust and
put it back in the oven okay for another
10 to 12
minutes until the crust turns slightly
brown pull it out let it cool off and
you are ready for a delicious pizza now
since keto has
became very popular there everyone in
their brother is making keto
products okay including the cauliflower
crust and there's one company that i've
used in the past that i really really
like
and it's called
the kibosh version now i don't get any
kickbacks or i have no affiliation with
this company
but when i see a good product with good
ingredients i recommend it so check out
these ingredients you got cauliflower
mozzarella cheese we got cheese culture
egg almond flour coconut flour
flaxseed meal cream of tartar and baking
soda so i really appreciate companies
that don't add all these additional
unfriendly keto ingredients and so if
you don't have time to make the crust
something like this is a great option
i've also used this to make lasagna and
it's actually quite delicious now let's
compare
that crust
with some of the other popular
versions of a cauliflower crust like
newman's own the first ingredient is
corn starch then they add rice flour and
then tapioca starch another brand name
is great value
rice flour corn starch tapioca starch
and then we have rustic they had wheat
flour potato starch and then caulipower
they had rice flour cornstarch twice and
the tapioca starch you don't want a
cauliflower crust with these ingredients
under the name of keto friendly or even
low carb i mean some of these have like
29 carbohydrates that's just for a
serving size this whole crust only has
three grams of carbs so in summary there
is a way to have both
healthy and delicious at the same time
but you have to make sure that the
ingredients are healthy if you're buying
crusts at the store now if you haven't
seen my pizza recipe video this was a
long time ago i created it so the
quality's not great i'm going to put
that up right here check it out
you